est-ce que nous avons parlé de politique
en tant qu'affaire de la cité oui et
nous l'assumons parfaitement le sujet du
commun est éminemment politique dans ce
qu'elle a de plus noble nous l'assumons
depuis la phase de candidature où il
était déjà question de réaction à
l'actualité et d'un fauteuilman c'est à
dire divertissement politique est-ce que
nous avons diffusé des postes partisans
absolument pas et je vais vous dire il
n'y a même pas sur nos pages le petit
poste classique appelant au barrage
républicain à l'entre-deux à
l'entre-deux-tours de la présidentielle
c'est dire notre rigueur sur le sujet de
la neutralité partisane depuis 6
semaines maintenant nous subissons avec
mon équipe une campagne de
désinformation médiatique et de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux mais
pas seulement des menaces aussi dont une
que je voudrais particulièrement
souligner le CCI émanation du CCIF qui
je le rappelle a été dissout par décret
validé par le Conseil d'État le 24
septembre 2021 a produit une vidéo
contenant les photos les noms les
prénoms de plusieurs membres de
l'association
pour être bien sûr qu'on soit bien
identifié malheureusement on sait ce que
ce genre de procédé fait peser comme
type de menaces et face à cela car là
nous parlons bien de notre intégrité
physique et pas uniquement d'un poste
d'un potentiel litige contractuel nous
n'avons reçu aucun soutien de la part du
cipdr au contraire même puisque c'est en
rentrant chez moi le soir du 16 mai
après l'avoir appris en direct que j'ai
découvert une lettre recommandée
demandant un remboursement qui nous a
été adressé quelques jours plus tôt et
plus précisément en date du 12 mai
voilà donc la réponse de l'État qui
entend lutter contre la menace
séparatiste sortir les parapluies à la
première attaque